Bruce Willis is Iconic as futuristic cab
driver at Corbin Dallas in The Fifth
Element but what if a certain Lethal
Weapon star was cast instead from a
rockar to a pretty woman here are some
stars who nearly appeared in the sci-fi
classic in an alternate universe Prince
would have played the role of Ruby Rod
it's a casting decision that's pretty
much perfect especially because Rod
exhibits the eccentricity and sheer
Swagger that the Purple Rain artist
already possessed in fact director Luke
ban said that he wrote the Ruby rodast
character specifically for the Grammy
winning artist B some wrote in a Reddit
AMA it was written for Prince I met him
he said yes but then he went on a world
tour for 10 years we couldn't find time
in his schedule in a Twitter post from
2016 the son even shared Jean Paul Go's
concept art of Prince and the role the
famed costume designer began working
with Prince early on in the film's
production though he found himself
butting heads with the Artist as part of
the Brooklyn Museum's the Fashion World
of Jean Paul gotier from the sidewalk
walked to the catwalk exhibit gotier
said this about the singer I showed him
my drawings but he didn't say a word
later Luke told me that Prince had been
very surprised and amused by my
presentation but that he found the
costumes a bit too AFF feminine
ultimately the role of Ruby Rod went to
Chris Tucker and the rest is history in
a separate ready AMA director Luke
Bassam revealed that he originally had
Mel Gibson in mind for the role of
Corbin Dallas you shouldn't tempt me man
ban wrote in the AMA I had asked Mel
Gibson first because he had his own
office next to mine at Warner Brothers
he peaked into my office every morning
to tell me that he was thinking about it
after 3 months he passed while it would
have been fascinating to Envision Gibson
as a futuristic cab driver who helps
save the human race it's difficult to
deny just how perfect Bruce Willis is in
the role in a retrospective chat with
Entertainment Weekly bam revealed that
he was initially hesitant to reach out
to the Die Hard actor because of how
costly his fees would be Willis however
was immediately on board with basson's
vision saying I just liked Luke I liked
the story I liked the idea I thought it
would be fun to go to France and make a
movie and money ultimately didn't seem
to be an issue for Willis as a Hollywood
Reporter noted the six cent star took a
pay cut to work on The Fifth Element
want a cup of coffee yes yeah it's hard
to imagine anyone else but mil yovich
inhabiting the role of the mysterious
but joyful Lilo the heart of the film
yovich expertly captures a raw intensity
childlike wonder and naivity that makes
Lilo such a beloved character and for
director still Luke basan meeting yovich
was a boon the two were briefly married
and reunited for the 1999 flick the
messenger the story of Joon ofar like
most of the leading casts in The Fifth
Element yovi's casting was in
fluctuation as several talented stars
were vying for the role according to
Jean Paul gotier Julia Roberts would
have occupied the lead role in an early
iteration of The Fifth Element
unfortunately Roberts and a number of
other stars didn't get the Fifth Element
gig in a chat with movie line showgirl
star Elizabeth Berkeley revealed that
she was also in the running for a role
in The Fifth Element though things
ultimately didn't work out Berkeley told
the outlet I got very close to getting
cast on The Fifth Element and Luke bang
couldn't have been more supportive
ultimately the cast of The Fifth Element
is perfect as it is however one can't
help but Wonder just how different Ban's
final product could have looked with Mel
Gibson Prince or even Berkeley in the
lead RS will we ever see the iconic cast
return for a potential sequel It's
unlikely B son says he has no interest
in revisiting his sci-fi classic the
director told comicbook.com in The Fifth
Element there's nothing in the DNA to
make a sequel they just live together
and they're happy and she's a Fifth
Element and that's it it will be just
for money and I'm not
interested